foreign
do you remember when Samsung spent an
entire three minutes straight in the
keynote just talking about the matte
black color
I get it
[Music]
hey what's up MKBHD here and this is a
Samsung Galaxy S21 Ultra and it's an
incredibly good phone I gotta say now
the thing is not only does it do a lot
on paper because we already know about
the big numbers the huge specs the ultra
story that's all still here
but it does a lot of stuff that doesn't
show up on the spec sheet a lot of
subtle tweaks and changes that turn this
from a really good phone
to a great one so of course I gotta
start with the Finish because well I've
been saying matte black everything for a
solid couple of years now to the point
where it's
it's on a shirt my car probably my most
precious possession is wrapped in matte
black and its name is Phantom so I guess
you could say this Phantom black Galaxy
S21 Ultra the matte finish kinda speaks
to me and like I said it's not going to
be on the spec sheet but this is a
really nice finish it's a really very
clean flat smooth black finish on glass
and then with a slightly different
texture on the metal housing around the
cameras and then it turns into your
typical glossy black around the edges
but just the whole look of this phone to
me is very intentional I'm on record
saying I actually really like it and
that was my first impressions video and
I'm sticking by that just the way the
camera module curves into the body of
the phone the way it looks like like an
overlay of another S21 Ultra on top of
the first one really the worst thing
about it is that it's still uneven so it
still rocks on a table but everything
else about this design I think is as
good as it gets I was kind of worried it
would look great out the box actually
and then just collect a ton of
fingerprints and look awful but this map
black has been shockingly good at
rejecting fingerprints so that's sweet
something you might have noticed also is
Samsung has a carbon fiber weave in the
camera module for like every other color
of this phone except for Phantom black
for some reason but luckily for less
than two bucks Channel sponsored D
Brands got you covered with a carbon
fiber camera skin so you can still get
that look easy so okay now that I'm done
raving about the design the Galaxy S21
Ultra as a sequel to the s20 ultra it's
actually largely the same phone it's got
a lot of the same big numbers the ultra
stuff is still here but there's a lot of
small intangibles a lot of small
adjustments that they've made that I
really like probably more than you think
and then like
I don't know how to say this without
sounding kind of full of it but I feel
like this phone was designed by or maybe
at least worked on by people who have
watched MKBHD videos
does that make sense like there's
there's a lot of things in here and of
course there's a lot of people out there
who have the same tastes and will like a
lot of these changes in any phone but
yeah this this exact phone feels more
like an MKBHD Edition phone than any
phone I've ever reviewed so you got to
start up front with that display this
has been a strength of Samsung and their
phones for years so you can expect good
stuff and you see that with the
improvements on paper right this is a
huge OLED that will finally do 1440p
resolution and 120 hertz at the same
time it gets even brighter up to 1500
nits tops so it's viewable in pretty
much any conditions and the new ltpo
panel Tech makes it actively vary its
refresh rate between 10 Hertz and 120
hertz to save battery but from my
experience has stayed very responsive
I've never noticed a dip in frame rate
in everyday use so it's managing it
really well which is a success but even
with all that stuff that's on the spec
sheet there's also all the stuff that's
not on paper like the fact that they
keep flattening the display even more
than last year this one doesn't spill
over the edges kind of at all anymore
obviously like that
it's also a little bit smaller and the
body of this phone it's still a big
phone don't get me wrong but it's not
like stupid big like here it is compared
to iPhone 12 Pro Max another pretty big
phone but it's actually a smaller
footprint here and next to the OnePlus 8
Pro it's still huge but doesn't seem so
overbearingly massive right it's
actually smaller than the Galaxy s20
Ultra going from a 6.9 inch to a 6.8
inch display and also the fingerprint
sensor is new I guess that would be on
paper too but they've switched to a
newer generation Qualcomm under display
fingerprint reader and that reader is
noticeably bigger it's 1.77 times the
size of last year I didn't notice it
being any faster even though it claimed
to be but just the larger sensor area by
itself makes the experience of using the
fingerprint sensor all the time much
less frustrating I have less failed
attempts it feels less finicky and maybe
someday the whole bottom of the phone
will be a fingerprint sensor but until
then in this world of wearing masks the
improved fingerprint reader is welcome
so also on paper Snapdragon Triple Eight
inside 12 or 16 gigs of RAM depending on
which spec you get fast ufs 3.1 storage
not expandable which is technically a
downgrade from last year but it's
something I haven't personally used in a
long time then High refresh rate display
and a 5 000 milliamp hour battery so
this phone is clearly a flagship
performer on paper but off paper there
are a lot of improvements to one UI
three on this phone that do probably
make a more meaningful difference to the
user experience versus just the bleeding
edge specs now I've said before I'm not
the biggest fan of Samsung's software
and their UI honestly I I've preferred
close to stock maybe oxygen OS is my
favorite non-stock option but
you can't sleep on Samsung software the
whole reason they do what they do is to
offer as many features as possible and
they are still at it there are tons of
features packed into these phones that
have a lot of potential for
customization and just letting you
tailor it to behave the way you want you
never have to dive in and use any or all
of the features because there's a lot
but they'll be waiting for you if you
have the time to mess with them I think
the stuff you'll first notice with S21
Ultra is the new volume control here
those sliders just a little cleaner
looking and one ui3 the new notification
grouping on top of Android just an
overall cleaner aesthetic and
organization to things like that the
stock apps and the improved dark mode
that I highly recommend looks great on
this OLED display and can actually net
you a little bit of extra battery life
but also the Google discover page to the
side of the home screen and Samsung's
launcher what
who told them to do that I did not see
that coming but hey if I worked at
Samsung and I kept asking for a Google
Play edition for all these years I guess
we know that's probably never going to
happen again but this is a little taste
to that it's as close as it's going to
get I do kind of wish the search box
showed up over here too like it does in
the Google app but hey this is solid and
I guess if they let me map Bixby to
Google Assistant all over the phone that
would have been the cherry on top but
anyway speaking of battery we again have
an ultra number it's 5 000 milliamp
hours and that looks great on paper
right in practice I've had a very good
battery experience now the thing to note
which is an ongoing conversation is the
Qualcomm Snapdragon chip experience
versus in other regions there's an
exynos version so this year with this
phone it would be Snapdragon Triple
Eight versus the exynos 2100. now the
initial testing results show a pretty
promising basically for those who
haven't known or haven't been filled in
uh usually the xnos version is much
worse with battery life and performance
in those regions initial testing is uh
pretty promising for the exynos 2100 I'm
going to leave that actual conclusion
getting to people who can get their
hands on both phones but for now with my
experience on the Qualcomm phone very
good battery life on one day I got four
hours of screen on time and ended around
50 percent the next day I had around
five hours had a little less at the end
of the day I never once killed it in a
single day it's pretty clear that the
combination of the Triple Eight chip and
the ltpo display Tech are working well
here I'd say it has what I'd call a
worry-free battery don't even really
have to think about it too much with
some super heavy use and navigation and
bright screen Outdoors all the time and
gaming taking lots of photos and videos
and maybe maybe you'll get to the end of
the battery but hey while we're here
let's talk cameras they are a big part
of the ultra a phone experience both
figuratively and literally speaking so
they hit all the check boxes of big
Ultra numbers again 108 megapixels 100
times Zoom 8K video all that stuff is
still here
I would say the experience has actually
changed more than the photo quality
photo quality is still roughly what we'd
expect from a high-end Samsung phone and
I'll get to that in a second but there
are more changes to how you get to that
photo and video that are better there's
countless examples of this so right when
you first open the camera app Samsung
asks you if you want to take Natural or
bright selfies instead of just
defaulting to Bright all the time I'm
glad they added that option they didn't
have to but that results in much more
natural selfies from that 40 megapixel
camera for someone like me with my skin
tone right off the bat instead of having
to mess with the exposure slider then
the 100x space Zoom which yes is
definitely extreme and probably still a
gimmick to most people it got a lot more
stable and easier to use thanks to the
subject locking in the viewfinder so now
when you're zoomed all the way in on
something the camera tries to identify
the subject of the photo you're taking
and locks the viewfinder to track that
instead of shaking around so much it is
slightly annoying when you're like
locked on to something that's not quite
what you're trying to shoot and then you
have to try to adjust it probably zoom
out and zoom back in but when it
correctly picks your subject it's great
the results are still insane and not
super usable but hey if you were using
100x before you'll be happier with how
much easier it is to use in this new
version you of course have the laser
autofocus added to fix the autofocus
issues we saw with the s20 ultra and I'd
say in 75 percent of cases it works it
sometimes still humps a little bit with
the really close up subjects but for the
most part it's solved and then the
camera app also now Auto detects when
you're trying to take an extreme
close-up and switches to macro but it's
not a separate macro camera as you may
have noticed this phone doesn't have one
because it doesn't need one it uses the
ultra wide camera which has autofocus
and a super close minimum Focus distance
so it actually takes really solid
quality macros and it does 4K 60fps
video from all the cameras now including
the selfie camera and it'll shoot 12-bit
Raw photos in Pro mode which is an
awesome capability that I I'll probably
rarely actually use personally kind of
like the 108 megapixel mode but it's
definitely a nice to have they even
added things like the director's view
which lets you record video from
multiple cameras simultaneously which is
enabled by the Snapdragon Triple Eight
potentially really useful for Vlog style
shooting and the use of two telephoto
cameras a 3X and a 10x seemed peculiar
at first but I've found it actually
makes a lot of sense so like I could
live without the 10x and most people
also could and the s21s don't have it
and that's fine but Samsung's committed
to offering that quality super far zoom
on this phone so if they did the 10x by
itself and not the 3x well then
everything from 1X to 10x would be
digital zoom on the main sensor and
that's not ideal
so if they only did the 3x and not the
10x well then everything from 3x in that
super far range wouldn't be quite up to
the ultra standard so they have a 3X and
a 10x and so now everything from 1 to 3x
is zoom on the primary camera everything
from 3x to 10x is either on the primary
or the second camera just depending on
what the lighting situation is and then
everything from 10x and Beyond is of
course on that little Periscope camera
and that's delivering some of the best
10x to 30X Zoom photos that I'm seeing
on any smartphone so that's
accomplishing what Samsung set out to do
now is it perfect no no camera's perfect
it still misses shots it still does 8K
at only 24 FPS the wrong frame rate and
most notably it definitely still fringes
on the edges with close-up subjects
absolutely but overall they've
controlled it a lot more with color and
HDR and focus and so overall the look is
what you'd expect just you easier to get
so at the end of the day when you go
down the list with the S21 Ultra
they did it like this this is the phone
that would have come out the lab if you
handed me an s20 ultra and said all
right go ahead and make any improvements
you want this is what I would have made
I would have updated the design I would
have flattened out the display I would
have added a little Google flare to the
software the improved camera experience
and I would have spent way too much time
on a matte black finish and named it
Phantom black
it's kind of the best they've ever done
oh and one more thing you might have
seen some shots throughout the video of
the limited edition icons drop that I
did with the brand a few weeks ago I've
also noticed a lot of you guys on
Twitter who uh missed out on that
limited edition drop so I've been
working with the brand on this for a
while behind the scenes and now you
guessed it icons is back and it's not
just limited this time it's back
permanently so for all 150 plus devices
in their category icons will live on
forever in red and black and triple
black but then also this is more than
just a re-release because we're adding a
few things we're adding that red and
black mask you saw red code mask and
we're also adding a new limited edition
colorway called silicon so it's the
matte black finish with a matte metallic
paint for all the icons looks pretty hot
if you ask me now if you're somehow
watching this in the future sometime
where silicon is over that limited drop
happened and you missed the train so
sorry but there's also some more limited
edition color ways planned in the future
so definitely let me know in the
comments what other sort of colorways
you want to see for icons either way
that's been it Galaxy S21 Ultra very
impressive phone very close to what an
MKBHD Edition might look like what do
you think of this phone and also what do
you want to see in the S21 review as
that will now be in the works either way
that's been it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace